well the the Bush administration seems
to have created a new legal category of
an illegal combatant or an enemy
combatant who who isn't entitled to
prisoner of war status which has many
rights the if you take capture a
prisoner of war that the it's a it's a
contract the prisoner says I I will give
up fighting and you say I will provide
you with benevolent quarantine for the
duration of the war and benevolent
quarantine is a legal status it has
rights we're denying the Bush
administration denies that that people
captured the people being held in
Guantanamo they are not prisoners of war
there are also not criminal suspected
criminals or accused criminals because
accused criminals also have lots of
rights in our political system they have
a right to an attorney they have a right
to know the charges against them they
have a right not to be tortured they
have all kinds of rights and and so so
there is this new status of a person who
has no rights or no no rights that fit
into any of the paradigmatic condition
legal condition legal statuses and
that's that's uh that's immoral illegal
unconstitutional I'm sure and and plain
wrong there can't be a human being
without some rights in the world there
can't be a legal status which doesn't
entail some set of rights so if if in
fact terrorists are if there are good
reasons for treating terrorists not like
prisoners of war then we should treat
them as criminals as murderers and we
should bring them to trial if we are
unprepared to treat them that way then
we should treat them as prisoners of war
or if if
if there are very good reasons for doing
so then you create a new legal status
but it has to be a status with rights
with clearly recognized rights that make
sense in the international community
because we don't we don't operate alone
and we want our soldiers when captured
and also our secret agents when captured
to be treated as people with rights but
you have to shut it down and you have to
bring the people who are currently being
brought before military tribunals you
have to bring them before civilian
courts I think that's the best thing to
do or you have to bring them before
military tribunals that are overlooked
that are watched and supervised by
civilians